welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and yippy K Christmas
lovers this is our Die Hard
breakdown a Die Hard is hands down one
of the best action movies ever made it
completely redefined the genre and took
it from mainly featuring Macho action
heroes to your more grounded Everyman
when the trailer came out the audience
left this guy's like a whip both swarin
egger and Rambo get mentioned in the
movie and originally they were both
wanted for the role however going with a
more grounded hero was an inspired
choice and this is seen right from the
off John mlan rides economy on the
airplane and even sits up at the front
of the limousine this is in opposite to
Dwayne T Robinson who we see arriving
later on sat in the back of the car
man's doing this even though the
passenger seat is empty because he views
himself as being a big shot whereas John
doesn't he struggling with his marriage
smokes and drinks jumps up Vents and
misses them and comes across as a blue
color guy it's little things like this
that make John mlan relatable and
someone that you instantly gravitate
towards the film of course also made
Bruce Willis's career and I think it
still stands as the best Christmas movie
ever yep it's a Christmas movie shut the
up and throughout this video we're
going to be pointing out all the little
details that you might have missed look
those those papers at the end they're
meant to represent snow see Christmas if
you enjoy it then please hit the thumbs
up button and if you're looking for your
new second favorite breakdown Channel
then Hans Bobby I'm your white knight
out the way huge thank you for clicking
this now let's get into Die Hard come
out to the coast we get together have a
few left a die hard's a loose adaptation
of the book nothing lasts forever by
rodri Thorp this was the sequel to the
novel in film the detective with a
ladder starring none other than Frank
Sinatra at the time the movie was a
massive success and Sinatra went to
Thorp asking for a sequel Thorp was more
interested in telling an action story
though and it took him a decade to put
the piece together at this point sonaro
was too old and lackluster sales led to
their being a little interest the
documentary on Netflix the movies that
made us it really goes into the making
of and though I don't just want to
Rattle that off you should definitely
check it out however it does include the
buildup to the script phase but it also
skips over some things that I want to
talk about here now originally clinty s
picked up the rights to it with the
actor planning to adapt it around the
end of the' 70s however things fell
apart and it was all sort of up in the
air until the end of the80s jumped in
1987 and screenwriter Jeb Stewart had
found himself in a pretty poor Place
financially several of his projects had
fallen through and thus when he was
asked to adapt the novel he jumped at
the chance now the original book was
inspired by The Towering Inferno in
which Thor had dreamt up a fight between
good and evil going down in a skyscraper
though Stuart was given a lot of
creative freedom there was still some
remnants of the story that remain in the
film we start off with a flight
attendant being a bit flirty and the
book had its main to Joe leand starting
up a relationship with one leand also
kills the first terrorist by breaking
his neck with mlan also carrying out the
same thing that's by accident in the
movie though and it sort of also speaks
to the tone that Stewart and the
director went with John McAn thought the
original work was a bit joyous and he
wanted to add some lighter touches and
comedic beats man was just coming off
the back of predator and though Joel
Silva was desperate to get him on board
he ended up turning it down that
happened three times and though he
agreed in the end he did want some
changes whose dead set on not just
making it another terrorist film and
even though the credits label them as
such they're more like highly
sophisticated robbers that's one of the
movie's big twists and it sort of shows
what mctm brought into the film Jeb also
said in the dark he had difficulty
writing the script because the book has
Leen trying to save his daughter after a
fight with his wife he then drove into
the night thinking about all the ways
that he was going to apologize heading
on the freeway he had a near-death
experience when he almost to the fridge
that felt fell out of a truck everyone
else had swerved to avoid it but he'd
been so distracted that he hid it head
on luckily for Jeb the box was empty but
this was the thing that caused the penny
to drop on the documentary Jeb said he
realized that if he died he wouldn't be
able to apologize to his wife this had
inspired him to build a film around John
and Holly who was a new character he
created for the film the pair of course
have an argument and the entire time
he's trying to get back to her so he can
apologize now there are other elements
that sort of play into the story but as
we know these were changed up for the
film there of course the name leiland
which now becomes mlan and Stephy leand
janaro now becomes Holly Hans grber was
called Anton little Tony grber with Hans
instead being the name of car's brother
nakatomi was also the claen O company
who were illegally selling arms to a
chillian dictatorship the story also
culminates with Gruber holding stephie's
daughter hostage and though he shoots
him off the building the daughter goes
too both end up dead because of it and
the brother also returns at the end and
Carries that a major shooting spree
again that tone was causing some issues
and sadly Jeb was fired from the project
the action scenes were care but then
Steven dusza did a rewrite with them
punching up the dialogue with more jokey
scenes this wasn't ready in time for the
production though and they started
shooting without a finished script with
just 35 Pages they started shooting with
Steven Evan to make up the other 99
elements of this somewhat affect the
final film and heavy spoilers about to
spoil the movie for you so at the end
the baddies want to escape in ambulance
which rolls out of the back of the van
they arrived in however when the film
starts we see them walk out the back of
it and can clearly see there's no
ambulance there it's a nitpick but it's
just moments like this that that show
how much the creative team were winging
it a lot of the movie was improvised
including Ellis calling H boobby with
rickman's confused reaction being
completely genuine
H
Bobby I'm your white
knight Willis also adab calling Holly
honey at the end as it showed a more
affectionate side to him mlan meeting
Hans was also thrown together as well
when they overheard rman messing around
in an American accent before then they'd
been trying to figure out how to get the
T to me without mlan instantly knowing
who he was they also had to find a way
that Hans would learn he was barefoot in
order for this to lead into the next
action scene so rickman's impression
made them realize he could pretend to be
a party guest and they shot the scene
without even rehearsing this added to
the spontaneous side of it and it's one
of my favorite moments in the whole film
on top of that people don't realize how
big of a risk Willis was at the time he
was a big star on TV but on the big
screen the man was coming off the back
of two big flops Bruce was beloved
though when seen as a TV heartrob which
made aror RI could negotiate an amazing
deal for the actor given $5 million he
became the highest paid actor in the
world with Willis being worth every
single penny man completely Nails the
part and I think what works about the
movie is that every character is great
in it
whether it's Reginal Val Johnson Alan
Rickman Bonnie bellia or even the slimy
Richard thorberg they're all
Unforgettable
terrorist did you get that now we begin
with John's flight landing in La which
is a far cry from the New York that he's
been used to La is boiling hot with this
creating a summer athetic now although
I'll die on the hill that this is a
Christmas movie it's of course been
contested ever since its release McAn
swears it's one too Raz Willis describes
it as being a s Blockbuster he said it's
simply the setting that makes people
think that way and the movie was
actually released on July 12th still
though mate I always watch it at
Christmas and look it's got a guy with a
beard in it that comes from the sky yay
now mlan shown is being vulnerable from
the off as he tightly grips the armrest
when they come to land one important
thing was that McAn wanted to show this
was a guy with flaws and make the movie
more grounded than what had come before
we get a lot of human moments like this
like the SWAT te member who walks
through the roseb Bush ulie picking up
the chocolate bars was also improvised
by Ali young as he felt to give the
character some extra depth to him the
movie is full of that as well with
John's wedding ring also playing a big
part of the shot too typically in action
movies the hero would get the girl in
the end but they'd spend the film kind
of flirting with them throughout here
though we instantly know the love story
is going to be more realistic with It
featuring a man who's dealing with his
marriage problems now the runway moment
was achieved through the magic of movie
making with them running out an airplane
and just pulling it around in circles
this gives the feeling that it's just
landed and he's then given advice to
make fists with his toes and make fists
with your toes this sort of foreshadows
the dangerous feet will be in later on
and glass is mentioned throughout the
film glass who gives a about glass
which of course backfires when it gets
stuck in his feet man would also come to
hate glass in the unbreakable Trilogy
which it it's a bit of a reach now now I
love throughout the film that he just
walks around Barefoot and again it helps
to add to his vulnerability the novel
had the events taking place over 3 days
without also being brought over to the
script itself however McAn was inspired
by A Midsummer Night Dream and in the
end he had this go down all on one night
it also really helps add to the pacing
because when're nearly always with John
it feels like we're going through it too
now the idea of him making fists with
his feet also pains to the idea that
he's ready to scrap no matter what and
this Pony pulls down a TIY bear which
has a red ribbon tied around its neck in
our Predator breakdown we pointed out
this is a running thing with McAn as he
also had one pop up in a plane during
his Hunt for Red October the passenger
with mlan then spots his gun and ah the
days when you could be a cop and travel
on airplanes with weapons now this lets
you know though he's never really off
the job and no matter what he's always
prepared we then instantly get the idea
that Jon's kind of weighing up the
options of his marriage as we see him
making eyes with the flight attending he
also sees a woman jumping into the arms
of her boyfriend reminding him of the
spark that they used to have according
to IMB trivia this is Terry Lind Dar who
also happened to be Playmate of the air
Holly clearly also feels the same way
too as we learn she's been using her
maiden name instead of using his however
the children still answer the phone like
this res see M speaking indicating that
he's not completely removed when JN
arrives though he has to learn the hard
way she's been doing this and
symbolically when we're in her office
the slow pan of photos shows him being
in the last one this thing gets slammed
down in Holly's frustration to show how
their marriage is pretty much done JN
didn't call before the flight and she
also instructs the May to make up the
spare room thus they aren't going to be
sharing a bed and the photo getting
slammed like the like button shows that
it's over it of course ends up helping
to hide his identity though and this is
so their connection can remain hidden in
the end it's flipped back up symbolizing
how the marriage could once more be
repaired I think both are kind of
married to the job as John wants to be a
cop in New York which takes him away
from his family Holly is kind of the
same too as when we first C to the party
she steps out of the elevator with
papers in her hand everyone else is
celebrating the party but she just walks
through the crowd focused on the work at
this point we also meet Ellis who tries
to get Holly to have a dinner with him
he says how about some mold wine in an
open fire and he is clearly a complete
SLE ball later on he does his best Tony
Manana impression on her desk indicating
he's got no respect for her or John's
marriage now one of the things you might
notice later on is that Ellis gets given
a kind of coke because of this right and
it's quite funny people have suspected
that the Buddies asked him if he wanted
anything and when he said Coke this is
what they thought he meant it's a great
little detail and he's basically 80s
business scumbag building off the back
of things like Wall Street now at the
airport John's picked up by oural and we
see as he rides out in nakatomi Plaza
like Michael J fox juring Back to the
Future Willis also had to shoot his show
alongside this Fox was famously shooting
on the day and then he'd go after the
set to film it at night the moments that
were done during the day had to be
filmed over the weekend but for Willis
to be fair it was a lot more simple most
of this movie takes place at night
however the shoot was still grueling and
very very exhausting th tza ended up
beefing up the other roles and gave
characters like Ary and poell way more
screen time I think it adds far more to
the film and Aral was originally going
to hear the shots in the garage which
would then build off the back this line
tell me you heard the shots you're
calling the police right now of course
I'm still coming by later what happened
next was that are you supposed to rush
up and in some ways come to the rescue
however they realized when filming there
was no way he could have heard it and
him being there added some extra
complications still though he gets a
moment to take down a bad guy so they
did manage to work him in in a cool way
that bit with the ambulance though
actually came from a previous script to
soua worked on with thieves also
planning to escape in one during 87's
the spirit and the car he plays
Christmas in Hollis by one of my
favorite bands Run DMC you got any
Christmas music This Is Christmas music
like the movie A lot of people have even
argued whether this is a Christmas song
because it doesn't play upon the
conventions of what we normally think
however it definitely is it's just got
its own unique voice similar to die hard
that's why I feel it's used in the movie
because it's commenting on how McAn
thought it might be judged from this
point we then go to nakatomi Plaza which
was actually Fox Plaza in real life this
is been used in a number of films and it
also popped up during speed a film that
this movie cinematographer Jan debont
directed being owned by foxman the
studio could use it without issue and
Jeb took a tour of it to incorporate it
into the script inside we see mlan
scarping out the place and taking note
of the cameras in Security on the door
he's told to take the Express Elevator
which he led uses to get up and down the
building quickly take the Express
Elevator taking the left to the 30th
floor this was the 13th floor in real
life with it being vacant while they
were shooting it inside we catch a
recreation of Frank L R's falling water
which has a pretty interesting backstory
to it why so this was going to show the
nakatomi corporation was so rich that
they bought it and then reassembled it
inside the building mlan also refuses to
drink which shows that he likes to try
and keep his wits about him however he's
still checking out the girls and even
getting a slight kiss you bloody cheeky
devil now at this point he meets Mr
tagaki and thanks him for the ride he
then takes him into the office and
brings up one one of the first of many
Pearl Harbor references we're flexible
Pearl Harbor didn't work out so we got
you with tape deck later on we see the
password of the VA is zagi which is the
name of a Japanese aircraft carrier from
the Battle of Midway the film was made
about this in 1976 with James sheda
playing vice admiral nagumo sheda also
played tagaki in this film and as I've
been saying it's all connected all
connected shirts are now available below
the video a George te's agent apparently
was called and told that they wanted to
give him the part but his agent didn't
end up passing this memo on to Kai found
out later and wasn't too happy
especially now the movie's become a big
success now on Holly's door Genero
spelled wrong and there have been some
few times about why this is the case on
Reddit there's a big thread theorizing
that it might be because she was going
back and forth on whether to keep the
name or not so didn't bother getting a
change to the right spelling that's a
little Christmas time time time in which
we give away all our crap theories to
less fortunate people now this video is
sponsored by Babel one of the top
learning apps in the world now I speak
English not very well H you might be
able to tell but I've always wanted to
kind of learn another language however I
didn't really stick in when I came to
school and just kind of messed about in
all my foreign language classes
regretting that now and if I went back
to University or somewhere to learn it
I'd have to pay thousands and thousands
but that's where Babble comes in now
when me and my wife got married and we
did it out in Mexico just us two and we
met with a couple called Diamond and
Nichola out there who were lovely and
hello if you're watching this it's been
a while anyway Nichola spoke flu in
Spanish and I just used to get so
jealous seeing her chatting away to the
waiters didn't know what she was talking
about and I was kind of just stumbling
through things and just not knowing what
to do therefore I made a promise to
myself I was going to start learning
Spanish and though that's kind of coming
along it's just made a a great
Improvement to my life now when I go
abroad I feel a lot more confident cuz
I'm not expecting them to know English
and just chatting back and forth which
really helps with how you feel on a
personal level now Babble is
scientifically proven to help you start
speaking a new language in just 3 weeks
lessons are designed by real language
teachers and Babel offers a 20-day money
back guarantee if you don't feel like
it's working Babble also offers live
classes too and with your subscription
you get two free classes they're also
now offering a lifetime subscription so
if you want to learn more than one
language this is the perfect place to be
Babble also teaches real world
conversations that give you practical
knowledge about travel business
relationships and more start 2024 off by
learning something new improve yourself
and check out our amazing deal with
Babble start speaking a new language in
just 3 weeks and get 60% off by just
clicking the link in the description
click the link in the description for
60% off and start speaking a new
language within just 3 weeks huge thank
you again to babble for sponsoring this
video and be very proud of yourself if
you take up this deal and start learning
something new for 2024 thanks now
Ellison tries to Bader Holly into
showing him the gift they got which as
we learn is Rox watch John says I'm sure
I'll see you later foreshadowing how
you'll see it later on at the end of the
film now at this point the bad guys
arrive with them being led by Hans gruba
the composer of Silent Night was called
France gruba and classical pieces often
accompany him the theme at the beginning
is based on o to Joy with this being
what's used later on in the film when
the bank vaults
open we also hear it in the bathroom and
Holly and John talk kids would love to
have at the house I would
have and Hans also hes there going up in
the
[Music]
elevator this all happens before it
explodes in that big scene just like how
the piece does when it's played in full
it initially starts off quiet and
Reserve before building up into what's
almost an explosion of music like how
it's used in the
film now initially there was some push
back on using this with the movie's
composer Michael Cayman calling it
sacrilege he didn't believe that it
should accompany violins but after McAn
brought up one of his favorite films A
Clockwork Orange C and changed his mind
and thought that it would work on top of
it the villain's German is full of
mistakes with lots of it being
grammatically incorrect thus when the
movie was released in Germany they
changed it to say that the villains were
just from Europe the car guns from
Europe as well with most of them being
made by sty and h& K Rickman also
brought this idea of his character being
unmistakenly European even down to how
he smokes a cigarette later on gruba
holds it like a European tends to Raz
mlan handles it like an American things
like this really added the performance
and even act as a clue in that scene to
what's going on now the truck they
sharpen has pafic Courier on the label
which was brought up on the Blu-ray
commentary production designer Jackson
dearia said the name's a jug Jud meaning
messenger of peace dearia also worked on
Die Hard with a engines and they placed
an Atlantic Courier truck in there to
show the difference on the East Coast
Pacific C also popped up during speed
bringing another influence in from this
film you can also catch one of his
henchmen about to walk directly into a
wall but they cut away just before this
happens couldn't have man just shifting
out the way cuz it would have stopped
the whole scene from looking as cool as
it does now I also love how Theo walks
up to the desk and he's rattling off
about sports games team rebounds right
feeds Worthy on the break over the a
man's constantly doing this and it kind
of plays another quarterback line later
on oh my God the qu back is toast in the
bathroom John and Holly's moments broken
up by a couple bursting in and these are
a far cry from John and Holly who are
completely distant they represent the
young love that they once had and the
closest set at one time that the pair
shared in a really cool bit of attention
to detail we can also see the pair later
together as the film wraps up the
actress here is Playmate Kim Ming making
this the second Playmate that appears in
the movie Holly and John end up in each
other's arms too showing how that
distance now being closed from the last
time they saw
them now what causes the argument is
Holly's name showing that she wants to
be a part from him her secretary also
busts in and calls her Miss janiro
Jano and in the back he can also hear
out to Jo again but the fact she calls
her Jano shows that's a name that she
wants herself known by Holly's called
out to deliver a speech with Jon clearly
also showing remorse for how he's
handled the situation we can clearly see
that he has a scar just beside his Peck
as well hinting at the idea air the
man's been in a number of scraps later
as he runs up the stairs and goes into
the floor under construction we can also
see that he has a tattoo on his arm it's
difficult to make this out throughout
the film but if you manage to catch it
you'll see a skull with a hat on it it
also has a tagline no one quits making
eagley fans suspect Jon's had special
forces training here locks everything
down though and we see how planned out
the job was the security guard just has
a waste coat but it's the same color as
the jacket that he takes from the main
security guard showing that had a fair
idea Tony also walks through the caros
and as he does this he says the
directions out loud Tony is also of
course an important name with it being
not of the main villains nickname in the
book downstairs he cuts open a Pacific
Bell panel and this company like corer
would return down the line in Die Hard 2
we catch John using a pay phone which is
also made by the same company and from
this point the movie hits the ground
running with gunfire breaking up the
party JN makes a break for her and on
the next floor he spots a woman in the
window across the street which to me
symbolizes the two choices he has man
could make a run for it and be free and
single but obviously he chooses to stay
with the old ball in chain and go
through the pain that's loyalty which we
see a lack of when H moves through the
crowd looking for daki he lists off his
entire life story and though that could
be a SPO Aus moment here no one takes
his place should have Bloody paid that
Christmas bonus mate anyway in the
office we see several models for oil
factories in oil RS this is likely
something out links in with CL in all
company from the novel who had more
nefarious plans hunen quotes his
education and rattles off things about
Alexander and his domain when Alexander
saw the breath of his domain he wept for
there were no more worlds to conquer he
also knows the make of takaki's suit
John Phillips London and says that he
owns two hey look are you showing off
and this hints at being Beyond just a
battle of the brawn and also teases
towards a direction things could go gret
is clearly well educated and more than
just a common Petty Thief makes you
instantly gravitate towards him and
wonder what it is exactly that he's up
to now not only is he cunning and smart
but he's also deadly I'm telling you
you're just going have to kill
me okay boom boom head shot he watches
he mercilessly murders to gaki and they
actually had a couple of issues with
Rickman when it came to guns man hadn't
really fired any and the movies that
made us talk about how he'd limply hold
them in a very theatrical way he'd also
Flinch when shooting too so they try to
cut around this as much as they could
still though you don't really pick up on
it and he exudes something sinister as
he just stares at the Vault teasing
something else coming down the line
John's pretty smart too and we see as he
triggers the fire alarm to try and get
an emergency response out to the
building however the bad guy says it's a
false SW and Tony goes looking for JN
you won't hurt me because you're a
policeman There are rules for policemen
This was later referenced in stranger
things with hopper and gregori you won't
do that why is that because you're a
policeman policeman have rules barely
managing to beat him JN looks at his ID
which later clues in pal that he might
be a cop John then writes ho ho ho I
have a machine gun on his chest before
sending him down in the elevator shout
outs to Reddit user master ball 9 who
pointed out that throughout the movie
the elevator dings signals to change in
Dynamics here it's to show that the
tables have turned and later on it
changes to Dynamics when mlan has hands
stupid
hands you're aane at the end it signal
just before the explosion which turns
the tower into a Towering
Inferno now during the filming of this
cinematographer John deom became trapped
in an elevator and started to panic that
he wouldn't be able to get out as you
mentioned he then yed IR speed with his
moment inspiring how he opened up that
movie now I was going to say this until
the end of the the video but I don't
think many of you are going to be still
watching so I just sort of drop it in
here huge thank you to everyone who
support us over the last year I really
really can't believe this support you
know when we first started these uh
classic movie breakdowns I was thinking
no one's going to watch these older
movies but you guys have came on board
and I just appreciate it so much so I
just sort of drop in here to say thank
you for all your support I hope you have
the merriest of Christmases and all the
best for 2024 thank you after making
notes of the bad guys names we see his
John Ry expr elevator to the roof John
jugs pass to play May poster and takes a
second look again playing on him being
flirty and not really locked into his
marriage you know what I'm saying mate
you get it but later on yet at the 48
minute Mark he ends up high-fiving this
poster possibly showing that it means
he's putting her in the friend zone
least least that's what I know it to be
at friend five now JN is a radio call
from the roof but at this point it's
ignored by the dispatch officers one of
these is Diana James who also appeared
in diod 2 on Holly's flight we also see
the address dring phone number put up on
the screen with these being the real
life ones for Fox Plaza quick quick
prank them tell tell how gr has Tak it
over at this point we meet Al Powell
renowned kid killer who bit dark who's
refused to fire his gun ever since he
shot a child with a toy one kind of wild
how they took this as a place to start
the character off from but he ends up
coming full circle from this man gets
told as a code 2 which requires Urgent
Response but it's without any Sirens
it's also the price look at the price of
look at look look BL bloody 88s pric is
that now he also sees he looks up at the
roof and mistakenly sees what he thinks
are light it's in fact gunfire and this
involved the production team setting off
blanks in order to create the effect as
Jon shoots it out with a bad guys who
watches call descends the stairs which
he later ends up fighting Jon on we can
even catch the chain there and it's sort
of like poetry they Rhyme now that's one
of the things I love about this film and
you can see why so many other movies
mimic this premise die a bus on a
mountain at the White House it allows
you to revisit and see how locations
change adding different Dynamics to
what's already familiar even just things
like the the 53 minute Mark you know you
see takaki's blood on the floor from
where he was shut really makes a
location as important as the characters
and it's you can't deny it's inspired so
much looking at you Batman Arkham Asylum
I bloody love you as well now dangling
out of the wall with his gun Jon barely
makes it to the VIN and we see his the
vest start to get dirtier and dirtier
the production team ended up creating 17
different vests for him with each one
being slightly darker than the last now
in the vent we see JN sparing up the
lighter that he ended up taking from
Tony's body this is something that helps
him navigate the vents and it also helps
him out later in the franchise in Die
Hard to when Jon takes down the plane he
does this by lighting the fuel dripping
directly from it the same letter there
is the one from this moment showing how
Jon kep there after the event of this
film Al goes up and knocks on the front
door which is when the god greets him
with his Southern an accent clearly all
of the crew have been practicing their
accents which explains how hor is able
to do one later on now as he reverses we
can actually hear Stevie Wonder being
played on aril's
[Music]
radio this is a little joke as John's
just said he's driving his car Stevie
Wonder also in what a blinking you'll
miss a moment you'll see the terrorist
body coming off the top of the cop car
as it reverses out moves really fast and
you kind of have to slow it down but if
you look out the back of AR's window now
you can see it jump off the front
welcome to the party pal returning to
takaki's office we see his John ends up
hiding under a table while a terrorist
shoots down over the top of it if you
pause and look at the shape of it then
you might also notice this is actually
the nakomi logo next time you have a
chance to kill someone don't hesitate
but sadly JN doesn't take this advice
later on cuz he could have easily have
killed Hans but he ended up hesitating
still I love how he's not a cold blooded
killer and a lot of the kills are either
by accident or in self-defense so he's
way more relatable and real life will
has suffered permanent hearing loss when
shooting the scene as they took a number
of measures to make the gun blasts more
impressive the blanks used in the film
were filled with more materials and it
made them louder and provided bigger
flashes plexiglass was also placed over
the top of Willis and this was to
protect him from splinters potentially
coming out of the wood however however
it increased the sound and Willis later
reveal this made him lose 30% of his
hearing since then he's warn hearing aid
and this was hidden during most of his
films you can also catch a casing
hitting Willis in the eye which meant he
had to get medical care for that right
after this too not a good moment but
still it's one of the most memorable
parts of the movie anyway at this point
we meet Richard who's promising his wife
stuff he can't deliver Monica I can get
us a table Wolf Gang and I are very
close friends like John you might also
notice that the man's wearing a wedding
ring however in diod 2 we see this as
gone showing that he and his wife didn't
work out also look closely look closely
at the man's crotch and you will see
that this man in fact has no
dick now Richard head over here as to
police radio and we watch as they close
in he has trouble getting it past the
news aner and I love how he cut to him
angry on TV just reminds me of something
recently when we caught a news reporter
doing something a bit naughty and again
it adds a bit of Comedy to the film John
radio's in and as he's moving through
the office and starts to Tor him by
calling him a cowboy another of a
bankrupt culture who thinks he's John
Wayne and in the end John says he was
more partial to Roy Rogers which helps
to create his catchphrase I was always
kind of partial to Roy Rogers actually
yipp Kai this is sort of
riing off a song by royu which is called
I'm an old
cowboy
radi
y however well Roy also gets a deep cut
at the end of the film as one of the
last things John says to hanses Happy
Trails Hans and the outro song for the
Roy Rogers Show was called Happy Trails
happy
tra to
you till we
meet
again John of course gives the name
right to Al over the radio to keep his
cover and I love how it kind of all
stems out from this line now they had to
edit these phrases quite a lot for the
TV versions with them saying yippi Kaye
melon farmer in this with Sam Jackson
also saying that in Die Hard with a
Vengeance yeah they found it down oh
that's L even for a fight Mel farmer
like you that's L told you a li didn't
even let man say the words he's famous
for and what a bloody bunch of melon
Farmers now later on Hans calls Him a
Cowboy again with a making reference to
another Weston still the cowboy well
this time John Wayne does not walk off
into the sunset with Grace Kelly John
corrects him and says that was Gary
Cooper with his actually being
referenced to a very similar film that
is 1952's high noon which involved A
Lone Hero facing off against a big group
of enemies which he defeated
single-handedly although he gets mock
for being American while Hans is German
Willis is actually more German than most
of the characters here when researching
it I found out Bruce was born in West
Germany with his father being an
American Soldier while his mom was from
Cassel anyway one of the big issues they
have with Jon is that bag of explosives
which plays into the plan later down the
line J also sits down and Sparks up a
cigarette with these being European ones
du to where the villains come from
anyway Deputy Dwayne arrives and pulls
rang taking over the situation he says
give be a bartender for all we
know which according to IMDb trivia is a
little joke because Willis worked as a
bartender before getting his big break
Holly then goes in and starts to
negotiate with horns which I always
thought was a really good touch though
it seems like she's just trying to help
the workers I ended up taking something
else on top of it when I was doing this
watch through looking at the photo I
think she's also there to find out if
they know about John as she kind of
seems relieved that it's face down
because they're not going to be
connected anyway outside the terrorists
send fire rockets and destroy the swats
plans to infiltrate the building we get
a shot used twice here with a rocket CU
this stuff is expensive to make mate the
had said 3,000 now John manages to stop
them by using the explosives and a CRT
monitor mlan Jabs the detonators in the
C4 and then drops it down but weirdly
this would need electricity to pop off
Mason Dell explained how this would
happen on Reddit with the user going
into why a CRT monitor was used in the
end detonators need electricity to
trigger which the CRT monitor could end
up providing they had a reputation for
their capacitors discharging high
voltage shocks if you broke the screen
so this is why that was needed to
trigger the blast as well in order to
get this effect they collected every
kind of camera flash bulb they could get
their hands on and line them outside the
building the fire was then superimposed
over the top of this creating the
explosion that we see here we also see
the news of uncovered hans's pass with
him being a member of a group known as
the vog free this roughly translates to
mean people's freedom and it's one of
the only things that we ever learn about
him though we know he's classically
educated and used to build models his
past life is very much a mystery Jud to
his brother also being a bad guy though
many people have theorized the peir had
a rough childhood later on he lists off
some demands to waste time including
trying to get people with similar causes
Around the World freed he asks that the
members of the new Provo front are
released who are based on the real life
provisional Irish Republican Army
there's also the Liber de Quebec which
was based off the front deliberation du
Quebec which was a separatist group that
kidnapped people and killed them during
the 70s these were government officials
with the event being known as the
October crisis lastly is Asian
Dawn I read about them in Time Magazine
okay and it turns out that these were
based on the Tamil Tigers St the suit
thing makes him seem up a Class 2 and
this is of course what helps him to act
like a hostage I do kind of see him and
Ellis as almost mirrors of each other
with this line sticking out especially
you use a gun I use a fountain pin
what's the difference both characters
are also people that were're meant to
hate who come between Jon and his wife
now I don't want Ellis dead mate yet K
is just out of his depth but they
clearly made the pair similar Ellis to
me kind of represents someone who thinks
he's a big player like Hans too but he
just can't cut it anyway we get news
reports with a psychologist breaking
down the attack by this time the hostage
should be going through the early stages
of the Helsinki syndrome the news
reporter then mistakenly adds in Sweden
which is then corrected back to being
Finland sinky syndrome as in hellsinki
Sweden Finland now though man is made to
look like a right knob what the
psychologist is describing is Stockholm
Syndrome the capital of Sweden is
Stockholm so who looks stupid now mate
you bloody do now after Alis has killed
the agents Johnson and Johnson arried
with them being listed as big and little
Johnson in the credits the Joe gets paid
off later on in the Saga as the guy
assigned to help mlan and Li freia die
hard is called Agent Johnson as well now
at this point Hans runs into John and he
goes into the name bu clay Rickman
actually knacked his leg up doing this
and had to stand on crutches for the
next couple of weeks you can actually
see that he's struggling as he tries to
get back up and he sort of limps as he
goes back to the gun for the rest of the
scene he stood with one leg up against
the wall and this was so he wasn't
putting any pressure on it now the
director talked about what the original
plan for this was and throughout the
movie Jon was going to notice that the
terrorists all wore the same wristwatch
this is how he realized Hans was one of
them but in the end they just cut the
scene personally I think he knows from
the off that Hans is a terrorist but he
doesn't suspect that he's the group
leader he probably doesn't think Hans
would go himself to do ay's work and is
instead just drawing out information
when you watch the scene he doesn't do
anything to impli his wife and in the
end just skirts around the questions mop
from New York New York
yeah got invited to the Christmas party
by mistake he then asks his name and
when he passes that he realizes that
he's going to have to test him further
Hans likely took this off the office
directories and it also shows how smart
that he is as per usual when you're
making a film you want to sneak in some
cheeky crew member names in the
background of a scene that's the case
with the board here too and in the
dsection we can catch several of the
crew at the top we can see davia who was
the head of the film's production design
and duser is of course the main writer
for the project Lassie is deont AKA The
cinematographer and a little bit of
trivia here Deon also Dutch now we're
going to do a rich here and I'm telling
you that for a reason but you might
notice there's a lot of Dutch angles in
this scene in case you don't know that's
when they tilt the camera angle to give
the idea that something's off with is
obviously also hinting to this suspicion
within Jon he ends up giving him an
unloaded gun to see what he'll do with
it and there's actually a really cool
detail on how he tricks him John ends up
holding the slide because he's loading
an empty magazine if he didn't do this
then it would have revealed itself to be
empty and thus he did this as a way to
make him think that it was loaded this
detail was first noticed by Yin on
Reddit and I think it's such a cool
thing to add into the film all I got to
do is pull the trigger this is basically
him trying to draw it out and had he
passed this test then John probably
would have eventually given him some
bullets anyway backup arrives and at
this point they Cho the glass John has
to run through it with Willis wearing
rubber shoes during it to help protect
his feet everything is effed up though
with him losing the detonators the
terrorists getting them and Dick doxing
his kids at this point mlan then quotes
WC Fields all things being equal I'd
rather be in Philadelphia this is
wrongly thought to be on his gravestone
but it's still helps to show that he's a
grounded hero that isn't confident in
the situation later on he tells pal to
apologize to his wife for him as at his
point he doesn't think he's going to
make it the FBI then cut the power which
allows the final Vault to be opened up
also the guy cutting it I think that's
the dad from Scary Movie I want the
building out yeah you could it can't be
done this opens the Vault up with 640
million bonds being worth roughly 1.6
billion after inflation inside we also
see some pieces of art including one by
Edgar de gas titled eold Deon you can
tell I'm educated as well now the next
part of the plan is then put in place
with the hostages being moved to the
roof and Johnson and Johnson bringing in
the Choppers this was apparently
nightmare to shoot and due to all the
noise at night from the set there were
several complaints thus the city stepped
in and said they were only allowed 2
hours every Sunday to shoot the outdoor
scenes now with this was a big problem
because they hadn't filmed the
helicopter or rooftop bit yet which were
obviously going to be massive scenes for
the movie McAn managed to break it all
down and realized they could get the
full thing done in an hour if they
managed to hit their mark on everything
in the end it's a massive part of the
movie that's played off brilliantly with
John fighting call while Han SE dicks
report the way he skids out and shoots a
gun in the air as well that always kills
me and man's got their moves to die hard
for now John is shot as well but he
manages to be call and this is done
through using that chain from before
this scene was important because it had
to show JN could not only outsmart them
mentally but that he could also outsmart
them in a physical fight outsmart them
is not the right word he beat them in a
physical fight now call ends up showing
up at the end of the movie still alive
and there's actually a little goof here
that you can see during the scene as
John backs up against the wall and lot's
gone you can spot the actor who play
call in the top right this is him
looking over the character while he's
also hanging but maybe man had lowy
powers and that's how he lived hey I'm
not playing the theory time again
but call was played by Alexander godov
Who in real life was a distinguished
ballet dancer during the movies that
made us we can see him performing and I
have to say wasn't expecting that anyway
John he's he's great it's I mean that in
a good way guy is fantastic anyway Johan
rushes up to the roof and he gets the
hostages to move back down but this
makes him seem like a terrorist to the
chopper it then leads into another great
moment with Jon jumping out of the way
of the explosion they were thinking that
they were going to have to use a stman
for this but Willis stepped up and said
he wanted to do this to him this was the
scene that would really sell him as an
action star and seeing him do this yeah
it it adds that authenticity you have to
realize this was a time in which they
worried people wouldn't take him
seriously and thus this shot was very
very important now next it takes us into
a style of screenwriting that also helps
to add vulnerability to the character
Jeb describes this as good news bad news
in which we see several events unfold
rapidly that change the Dynamics so
firstly you have the explosion which is
the bad news but the good news is that
he's able to jump off the building this
happens with the hose which is a
reference to the film safety Last which
has helped the Pioneer a hell of a lot
of stunts also got referenced at the
starter Back to the Future which we've
just seen a breakdown of on on the
channels bit of spam there now the the
hose then gets torn off the wall in the
explosion but the good news is that it
gets stuck on the building the bad news
now is that he's stuck on the outside
but the good news is that he's got a gun
from here he can then get into the
building but the bad news is that the
hose holders now fallen this is pulling
him down but the good news is he's able
to get it off and that's how you make a
very tense action scene now the Indiana
Jones films also used it to great effect
with Mission Impossible bringing it
across too we also watch the helicopter
Falls which was done with the model and
then slowed down seeing what it looks
like at normal speed it's pretty
hilarious but yeah slow motion makes
everything better a Hans wants to use
this explosion to cause confusion and
make the police think that they're all
dead by the time they're able to finally
pick the rubble clean and discover the
truth they'll be on a beach earning 20%
sound bit 20% sound a bit like Sean
conry there but yeah John gets left with
two bullets and the man has to outthink
the situation and strap the Beretta to
his back by using Christmas tape this is
a Beretta 92F which is the same prop gun
also used by Mel Gibson in Lethal Weapon
It's exact same model I don't mean that
it's the same type of gun it's the exact
same gun that appears in both films now
he shoot hands and he sent out the
window and we get a happy ending than
what happens in the book now what's so
impressive about this bit is that Alan
Rickman performs the stun which adds so
much to this moment the idea of a
villain falling would be AED in a lot of
other movies like Batman 89 and the
third Ninja Turtles film however this is
by far the best because we see that it's
Rickman Falling For Real the stuntman
also played a little prank on the actor
and they said that they were going to
drop him on three however they said one
and then let him go so that shock look
is it's completely real he also said on
movies that made us that this was done
in the last day of filming and that was
in case anything went wrong which he
only figured out after now out side John
introduces his wife is Holly Janeiro but
she corrects this by saying Holly mlan
away Holly Holly janiro har M finally
the Pair worked it out and realized how
much they mean to each other car then
returns and we get some unused music
from Aliens playing over Al's hero
moment this is the song resolution and
hyperspace which though on the
soundtrack was never in the film at this
point Holly punches Richard proving
finally the man has no dick this man
right here he has no dick which would
further get proven in Die Hard 2 anyway
that wraps up the film and huge thank
you for joining me as we went back
through it that save the best Easter egg
to last there and die hard would of
course gone to spawn a number of
copycats with even films like Conair
getting labeled as die hard on an
airplane there was under siege which was
die hard on a bow with Under Siege 2
being die hard on a train Die Hard 2
even became Die Hard in an airport and
it pretty much reinvented the genre it
was also put on the national film
registry with it being labeled as
culturally significant again I hope you
guys have a great Christmas or you
haven't you've had one and uh yeah huge
thank you for all your support of the
last year really meant a ton of me
watching you guys support us and thank
you so much for sticking by us as we go
through these old films if you want to
get access to these films early then
please also consider clicking that join
button this will let you get the audio
versions as soon as we make them and
edited ones before anyone else and huge
thank you for signing up to that if you
did it now we will be back with Back to
the Future Part Two And yes going to
finally get back to Terminator 3 and
alien resurrection and don't want to
mate but I've got I've got to keep going
and if there's any other films you want
to see me break down then let me know
below as for next year I want to tackle
some big ones the Mist that's what I
want to do Citizen Kane Yeah couple of
big on and if you want to watch our
first back to the feature breakdown then
that's on screen right now huge thank
you to everyone who's checked that out
as well I love you guys and thank you
for all your support again but out of
the way I've been Paul you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace y k mother chompers